it's about time Barbie was brought into
the real world the movie was a ton of
fun behind the scenes Margot Robbie
hosted a Barbie sleepover no Ken's
allowed there were a ton of sneaky
little edits in the movie to hide
margot's explosive laughter that ruined
a ton of takes and of course the secret
behind the Barbie energy they use to
find the perfect cast so this cast
didn't really know each other before
they shot the movie well not that some
of them could remember anyway he said
maybe we like said hi we were on a whole
panel together America it's fine
apparently America Ferreira can't
remember any of her co-stars for the
life of her and it kind of became the
running joke among the cast She's Like
America you don't remember and I was
like oh no what America Ferreira and
Kate McKinnon both attended the same
drama summer program at Northwestern
University you're Kate your funny cake
America did this stunning very dramatic
monologue that had everyone's jaws drop
in in awe and Kate well I played a bug
in my show like I said before the cast
had a ton of fun behind the scenes of
the film One Night in particular Margot
Robbie hosted a Barbie sleepover at
claridge's hotel in London before
filming even started they shared beds
wore pajamas ordered room service and
played games together this was where
they discovered that America was
exceptionally competitive I am extremely
competitive nobody told me that it was a
sexy Barbie sleepover apparently
everybody was in really pretty silk
nightgowns and America was in some sort
of Grandma flannel attire somehow
simultaneously looked like an old lady
but a five-year-old at the same time it
was the cutest the Kens were also
invited to the sleepover but only to
visit Ryan Gosling actually couldn't
make it so he sent a singing telegram it
was an older Scottish man in a kilt who
played bagpipes and recited the speech
from Braveheart what a guy and So
speaking of Ryan Gosling apparently he's
like the funniest guy around he is the
most comedically gifted actor Margot
Robbie says that we're apparently
sleeping on Ryan Gosling's incredible
comedy skill so cool he says that he's
deaf well known for being a great
dramatic performer but very rarely do
people give him the comedic chaps but he
so well deserves in this movie he's
funny on like a completely different
level I see you Ryan I see you she also
says that she ruined a lot of takes
because she just couldn't stop laughing
through them the editor had to like cut
away before she started laughing in
order to salvage the take and then she
cuts it back to him because he's so you
can see at certain scenes where the
corners of her mouth start to rise right
before they cut away from her
Issa Ray had no idea she would have to
learn the dance sequence she heard there
was going to be one but thought she
wouldn't have to be involved because
well she's not a dancer I was like oh
cool that's that has nothing to do with
me and then they sent me like the
footage to rehearse it she was in DC at
the time and had to learn it in under 24
hours the rest of the cast had already
been working on it this is literally my
worst nightmare I'm not a dancer her
friends were there with her as she was
trying to learn it they were giving
major moral support and when I girl get
it like one two one two get it and then
apparently after she did end up learning
it by the time they'd gotten to set the
choreography had been changed to
something completely different go figure
who else had a Barbie Dream House when
they were a kid welcome to Bobby's dream
house if so I'm sure you can relate to
Margot Robbie on this one she was pretty
much down for whatever Vision Greta
Gerwig had for the movie but she just
had one request she had to have a dream
house with a slide that went from her
bedroom all the way down to the pool
that was it that was our only request or
even the tone of the movie none of that
I was just like I just want that slide
so bad that idea was actually inspired
by the Barbie dream house that Margot
used to play with as a kid so like
there's been a lot of conflict over
Barbie and Her Image throughout the
years since her origin in 1956 and a big
part of that was the reason why America
Ferreira didn't really have an interest
in being in the movie she never felt
like she was represented in the Barbie
world and ultimately didn't feel like
she belonged there the standard of
beauty and aspiration and the icon of a
woman the only reason she agreed to even
read the script was because Margot and
Greta were involved and she deeply
respects and admires their creative work
but ultimately she just didn't think the
movie would be for her how do we make
that relevant to girls today who did not
grow up seeing themselves represented
what pulled her into it was actually how
they addressed both the positives and
the negatives of Barbie and her impact
on society okay so Barbie was created in
1956 that whole time up until 20 Dean
she had an arched foot moving forward
she was given flat feet and adjustable
ankles the scene in the movie where
Margot Robbie steps out of her high
heels with her arched feet were really
important to highlight that change in
the narrative are on the ground when
Barbie gets to step into the real world
doing that scene was really important to
Margot because she wanted it to be her
actual feat not inserts she said she
hates watching scenes in movies that
she's done where she knows it's not her
real hands or feet or whatever it may be
I always say the direct away please let
me do all my own things I don't I don't
like knowing that I didn't do it Greta
Gerwig and Noah bomback wrote the script
together during the coven lockdown and
apparently had a really fun childlike
time doing so they described the writing
process as playing with dolls because
they had to rely a lot on their
imagination for inspiration due to the
lockdown and well the characters were
dolls when Margot Robbie first read the
script she thought it was so clever and
funny that it wouldn't actually be able
to get made she also thought that Mattel
as an actual character in the film would
make it even harder because she never
thought they'd be able to secure the
rights to make the movie at this point I
couldn't imagine anyone else playing
Barbie other than Margot Robbie but
ironically she never envisioned herself
as the one playing the role it wasn't
until years down the line into the
development of the film that she could
finally picture it there were several
attempts to create that Barbie movie
over the years it even had stars like
Amy Schumer and Anne Hathaway attached
to them but they never were able to get
off the ground Margot Robbie kept tabs
on the project as she was really
attached to bringing it to life but it
wasn't until 2018 that she saw an
opening to make it happen and had a
meeting with the CEO of Mattel where she
ended up pitching her production company
Lucky chap as the one to bring it to
life so after learning about this I'm
definitely gonna be looking for Barbie
energy everywhere yes during the casting
process Greta and Margot were
specifically looking for actors who had
what they called Barbie energy they said
someone like Gal Gadot is the epitome of
that Gal Gadot is Barbie energy because
Gal Gadot is so impossibly beautiful but
you don't hate her for being that
beautiful because she's so genuinely
sincere and she's so enthusiastically
kind that it's almost dorky it's like
right before being a door unfortunately
Gal Gadot is available but they did find
their Barbie energy in Issa Ray America
Ferreira Dua Lipa Kate McKinnon and like
tons of others once production went
underway lucky chap hosted weekly movie
screenings on Sunday mornings that were
used to reference Barbie they called it
movie church and used it to really hone
in on all that Barbie energy The Best
Day Ever it is the best day ever so who
else is getting ready to plan their next
Barbie sleepover after hearing about
this one it seems that after years of
trying this is the real world Margot
Robbie and Greta Gerwig were the perfect
combination of people to bring this
iconic character to life the Barbie
energy Ryan Gosling's unbeatable
depiction of Ken on the Malibu and the
perfect Barbie Dream House were clearly
crafted to Perfection what's your
favorite live-action Barbie moment don't
know
oh